[Musique]
et on commence ces informations Gabriel
par une inauguration qui avait lieu ce
matin au Mesnil-le-Roi en présence de
Valérie Pécresse oui Mathilde d'après un
an de travaux leur était à
l'inauguration de la première tranche de
la nouvelle voie verte pour l'occasion
la Présidente de la Région Île-de-France
s'est rendu sur place comprenant des
pontons des zones de protection
écologiques ou encore des parcours
sportifs cette voix va permettre aux
familles et aux personnes à mobilité
réduite de profiter à nouveau des berges
et de développer l'usage du vélo on
écoute les propos recueillis par Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude on sait que c'est une
grande demande de nos concitoyens de
toujours développer des aménagements des
pistes cyclables pour pouvoir pratiquer
le vélo que ce soit pour aller au
travail ou pour le plaisir en famille et
donc là on a un magnifique projet qui
permet à la fois de profiter de la
nature en bord de Seine et aussi de se
déplacer à vélo
et la deuxième phase des travaux
Mathilde concernera le raccordement des
pistes cyclables en bord de Seine des
communes du Pecq et de Maisons-Laffitte
à Mantes-la-Jolie maintenant un lycée a
été visé ce matin par un tir de mortier
d'artifice où il s'agit du lycée Jean
Rostand et ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'il est pris pour cible ce matin peu
avant 9h un individu cagoulé avisé le
personnel de l'établissement notamment
la proviseur adjointe avec un tir de
mortier un élève a été légèrement blessé
au mollet une enquête a été ouverte et
l'individu est recherché en réaction les
professeurs du lycée ont exercé leurs
droits de retrait les élèves eux n'ont
pas eu cours cet après-midi les salariés
de Keolis viennent d'entamer une
quatrième semaine de grève oui la
mobilisation ne faiblit pas sur le site
de Montesson mobilisé depuis quatre
semaines les grévistes de l'opérateur de
transport public demande une
amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail et le rétablissement de leur
prime supprimés ce matin le député
insoumis des Yvelines William Martinet a
apporté son soutien au grévistes sur
place un mot de sport maintenant avec le
retour de la Transat Jacques Vabre oui
la présentation de la 16e édition de
cette course transatlantique en duo
s'est déroulée cet après-midi à Paris
alors parmi les 200 participants de
yvelinois Louis Burton originaire de la
selle les bornes près de Rambouillet
partira sur Bureau Vallée de son côté le
verset Éric Bellion s'élancera sur son
nouveau bateau stand as one départ de la
course le 29 octobre depuis Le Havre
pour rejoindre la Martinique et on
termine ces informations avec la
cinquième édition de la Nuit du droit ça
aura lieu demain soir oui tout à fait
depuis 2018 cet événement célèbre le
droit sur tout le territoire chaque 4
octobre alors l'objectif c'est de
célébrer l'anniversaire de la
Constitution et de mieux la faire
connaître aux citoyens en organisant des
rencontres à Versailles plusieurs lieux
où vous leur porte au public c'est le
cas du tribunal administratif ou encore
du tribunal judiciaire la Faculté de
droit de l'Université Versailles
Saint-Quentin à Guyancourt participera
également à cette nuit du droit vous
pouvez consulter les lieux et les
programmes en détail sur les le site
pardon qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran bien merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier et si vous aussi vous voyez une
information ou une image qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news